congratulations on the film sir well
thanks carlos i appreciate it thank you
was it the um
the complexity of this character in a
situation the main thing that attracted
you to this
yes it was and also
getting a chance to work with martin
campbell his work i i i've never
i didn't know martin before this film
um i saw this extraordinary tv series he
did
when i was living in london in the early
1980s called age of darkness
superb
he eventually made a movie of it with
mel gibson i believe i didn't see that
but but i knew who martin campbell was
and i think he
he rebooted the old james bond franchise
and
so there was that aspect of getting to
work with martin i loved the script i
love the originality of
of a hitman an assassin
who
is suffering from this early onset
alzheimer's dementia
uh that that gives an added attention to
the whole
piece of entertainment you know
and it gave me something to really uh
research uh that that world
uh of that horrible affliction of
dementia and
alzheimer's
um martin's movies are known for
tremendous action and this one lives up
to that as well is the physicality part
of it still really fun to you
it is it is i i i you know i i love
still
working out with these stunt guys i have
a fight coordinator we've done 25 movies
together
we're about to do our 26th i fly off to
ireland tomorrow to shoot another one
and
i love it i'm like a kid in a candy
store i loved it
choreographing these fights and uh i
don't do my own stunts i i hastened a
lot but i i love doing my own fighting
you know
yeah
and i i try and do it as
well i'm 69 years of age now so i try
and do it as a
as an older guy and i'm not trying to be
35 or 40 or even 50. you know
i think that's important for audiences
to
see that you're you are your age you
know what i mean
of course
you know there's a line that you say i'm
paraphrasing a bit but something about
you know i've done some crazy things as
your character says in the in the movie
when you when you think about your
career in making movies what's the
craziest thing
that you can remember that you've done
for a film
uh
craziest thing
god you've thrown me carlos
i mean it's just the act of making any
movie
especially if you're on location
and you there's like a hundred
fifty to a hundred crew members
and uh
you know various actors and actresses
and stuff and it's like i i often wonder
how any movie gets made i don't care how
good it is or how bad it is it's just
this extraordinary group of people from
all walks of life
coming together on the side of a
mountain
or on the sword i remember in batman
begins
christian bale and i are at the foot of
this glacier
doing a
fight i'm instructing him on something
and you know during a coffee break
i thought
this is
this is really
this is a real glacier i mean nowadays
it would look it it does look actually
cgi but it was actually a real glacier
moves like three inches every day
and we had these we had these ice
wranglers this was up in iceland by the
way yeah these ice wranglers who so when
christian and i would be on
you know and the cameraman
and uh
you know doing our scene and then these
ice wranglers would suddenly say stop
everybody off so we'd come off and we'd
wait there two or three minutes and
slowly this glacier
would
like three inches
and the ice you were working on would
slightly buckle a little bit
and they would go on the ice wranglers
would go on and check it and say okay
you can continue
christian merely
what the hell are we doing
so that that was kind of crazy but but
fun too you know it was
absolutely tremendous well sir thank you
so much for the time um and i thoroughly
enjoyed the movie i'm looking forward to
whatever it is next taken for at some
point hopefully um talk to you soon
thanks thanks